[Music]
it's really just like
me processing a breakup me processing
losing somebody
that was
what so much of my world was surrounded
by and
it's just me trying to be candid and
real with people because ultimately
that's the only way i'm ever gonna
connect
[Music]
[Music]
i went through a period of
freedom and then i went through a period
of fear and then i came back around to
find freedom again and that was a huge
lesson in itself is that fear is not the
way
this is gonna work and so
coming back around to freedom and trust
has been a huge one for me
[Music]
ice baths have been like pretty game
changing for me like a sauna an ice bath
and like some meditation and like if i
can keep that going i really do go out
there i give 130 because the thing is is
when you get on stage no matter how
tired you are you see all these people
have showed up and there's only one
option it's just like to give and and
if you give that much you also receive
that much
[Music]
as you get older you start to just feel
like you are you really want to start
pushing boundaries you really want to
start like breaking down walls and and
doing things that have that have maybe
never been done before and that that's
that i think that is a sign of maturity
[Music]
[Applause]
you